toiture végétale panneaux solaires
isolation laine de bois avec ce nouveau
multi accueil la ville a souhaité mettre
en avant le bien être et l'écologie pour
les enfants le toit végétalisé les
panneaux solaires la structure bois pour
la construction et pour l'isolation
ainsi que tout l'équipement que ce soit
les lampes led
ça fait partie aussi de non seulement de
la demande mais surtout c'est aussi une
économie pour la ville en frais de
fonctionnement
construit en lieu et place de l'ancien
square du 19 mars le bâtiment de 670
mètres carrés pourra accueillir 35
enfants de 0 à 3 ans entre 8 heures et
18 heures si le regroupement d'un
multi-accueil de 15 bears de 15 places
et un autre
une structure qui s'appelait
initialement une halte garderie de la
place donc ces deux structures ont
fusionné avec les équipes pour ouvrir à
nouveau multi accueil d'une capacité de
35 places avec les cinq équipes de
chaque côté existantes dans ce qui fait
une équipe au total unique et
disciplinaire de dix agents avec ce
multi-accueil la ville atteint
aujourd'hui une capacité d'accueil de
300 enfants